مؤشرات عده تشير الى الخطر الذي يخيم على
المنصه مسؤول كبير سابق في تويتر اعتبر ان
اسلوب الاداره الدكتاتوريه التي يتبعها
ماسك يدفع الشركه الى اخطاء تجاريه غير
مقصوده المسؤول وضافه ان طرح شركه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعيه الفاشله لميزه التحقق
المدفوعه هو مثال على كارثه مرت وسط
الفوضى التي جلبها الى الماسك الى تويتر
عناوين هنا وهناك في الصحافه الامريكيه
تنتقل الى الماسك مالك شركه تويتر الجديد
لما اجراه من تغييرات اعتبرها البعض صادمه
رئيس قسم الثقه والامان الذي استقال من
منصبه بعد استلام ماسك وصفها بغير
المتناسقه وقد تؤدي لكوارث وحسب راس الذي
وصف اسلوب اداره ماسك للشركه
بالديكتاتوريه حاول هو وزملائه فني المالك
الجديد عن تنفيذ فكرته بطرح نظام الاشتراك
الشهري بالعلامه الزرقاء لكن مخاطر
كبيره وربما مصيريه رئيس تحرير قسم
التكنولوجيا في الجارديان البريطانيه
دانيلو حذر من تحول المنصه الاشهر في
العالم من شركه مربحه الى اخرى مفلسه
وخصوصا على خلفيه انسحاب عدد وزن من
المعلنين او تعليق اعلاناتهم
اضافه بالطبع الى الازمه مع ابل التي الى
الان لم يصدر اي رد منها وحسب موقع ميديا
ماتز قامت 50 من اكبر مئات شركه معلنه في
تويتر بوقف التعامل مع المنصه خسائر جديده
لتويتر بنحو مليارين دولار صرفتها هذه
المؤسسات عامه 20 20
بعكس التيار عززت هذا التوجهات تغريده له
تعهد فيها بنشر تفاصيل عن قمع حريه
التعبير التي كانت تقوم بها الاداره
السابقه لتويتر الاكيد انه منذ دخول الى
المسجد الى تويتر دخلت المنصه الاجتماعيه
الاكثر انتشارا حول العالم في نفق ازمات
اصبحت تهدد وجودها انسنا الناسي العربي